What's up, tough guy? How you doing?
[Arabic recitation]
That's something else, buddy.
You be careful with that firepower.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
A very brief narration this evening that
I think many of us know or most of us
know and that really is what knowledge
is, isn't it? It's not the new exciting
novelty that you've never heard before
which is referred to by the scholars as
or
knowledge is when a person gets down
under the foundation
and
reassesses
takes inventory of what he already knows
but puts those pieces together. Most of
these narrations that we discuss every
night except for the rarity
we are we all already know. The problem
that we have as we've mentioned before
and the problem that really most of
humanity has and struggles with isn't a
lack of knowledge most of us know. It is
either a lack of understanding of
application or the intricacy intricacies
of what they already know or a lack of
motivation to implement and uphold that
knowledge.
This narration
has been was featured in the 40
narrations of Noahi. It's actually 42
narrations very well-known book. it
is the beginning step for most students
of knowledge and memorization of hadith
after the book of Allah since
we put pen to paper.
This narration is on the authority
of
ibari.
Tamimari tells us in Sah Muslim
that the prophet sallall.aii Wasam once
said to the companions
three times.
[Silence]
So he mentions five. Now the reason that
we want to discuss this narration is not
just to discuss its meanings and remind
of its meanings but also to correct a
misunderstanding. This this
misunderstanding
is also for native Arab speakers. But
the misunderstanding becomes compounded
with respect to those of us who rely
on translation of the narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. Most of
the time this narration
is translated as
that the religion is advice.
The religion is advice. We've heard this
before. The religion is advice. What
does that mean? Even that limits the
meaning and takes it out of the context
that it was intended.
Even in Arabic, the word
is used to refer to advising someone. So
commonly
that this is the only understanding of
this word that usually comes to mind.
The word the word
in the Arabic language is to filter
something and purify something.
This is called aus in the Arabic
language.
When a beekeeper
takes the wax out of the honey and then
purifies the honey and filters it, this
process is referred to as ana in the
Arabic language.
Now this translates to a metaphorical
and aa in this context is allegiance,
loyalty. That is what here means. The
proper translation of this should be
meaning our religion is an allegiance
and a loyalty.
It's an allegiance.
That's why they said to who? An
allegiance to who? They didn't say of
who. Meaning it's advice of who? To
advise someone. No, they said to who? To
whom is this allegiance?
He said to Allah
and to his me to his book and to his
messenger to the leaders of the Muslim
and their general folk to every Muslim.
Now the narration makes sense because
when we say the religion is advice
advice to whom? to Allah and his book.
What what does that mean? How do you
advise Allah and his book?
And so the word
advice is part of loyalty,
but it is not loyalty. Loyalty is a much
broader term than that.
So advice is included in the term
loyalty.
Yesterday, for those of us who were
here, most of us were last night, we
discussed
priorities.
We discussed the narration of the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam speaking
about priorities.
Those who prioritize the dunya and those
who prioritize the hereafter.
Most of the problems that we have is a
mixup in priorities.
That list is constantly shifting and
changing.
However, if our priorities are set
perfectly,
99% of your choices have already been
made.
All you have to do is follow through.
And so this narration is setting into
focus for those who prioritize the
hereafter over the dunya.
What are the priorities of the
hereafter?
Who is my allegiance to?
Who does my loyalty belong to?
Here the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us that our religion is
an allegiance. It's loyalty. Loyalty to
whom? Loyalty to Allah, to his book, to
his messenger, to the leaders of the
Muslim and to the general folk of the
Muslim. This is to whom our allegiance
belongs to. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
speaks in the Quran about every type of
agreement between people as a me as a
type of allegiance.
He even refers to the marriage contract
as an allegiance. It's a me and he
refers to his book and his messenger as
a messenger who comes with an
allegiance.
And this is why when people would accept
Islam, they would come to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, he would extend
his hand. They would put their right
hand in his right hand. And he would
tell them, "I hereby testify that none
is rightfully worshiped but Allah
Muhammad Allah. I pledge allegiance to
this, to that, to this and that,
whatever it was that was appropriate for
that person and that people make making
those allegiances. This is what our
religion is. It's an allegiance. It's an
allegiance between us and Allah. We have
pledged an allegiance to Allah
that if we follow through with A, we
will receive B. He says subhanahua.
He says, fulfill my allegiance and I
will fulfill yours
and me alone. Fear, fear only me alone.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala. So this
narration tells us that list of
allegiances.
Our allegiance is to Allah.
We do not do anything in the obedience
of other than Allah that interrupts our
obedience to Allah. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said
he says there is no obedience
to a creature of Allah when it involves
the disobedience of the creator.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam says
it is allegiance to Allah. It is an
allegiance and a loyalty to the book of
Allah. The prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said
he says every condition that people
place in their contracts and allegiances
with one another if it is contradicting
to the book of Allah it is an invalid
condition even if it were a hundred
conditions it is invalid out of the gate
why because Is the Muslims allegiance is
to the book of Allah first?
What about a human being? Who does our
allegiance f first belong to? The
messenger Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam.
We do not obey anyone in the
disobedience of Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam. No human being carries the
authority of our messenger. No one. No
human being carries the authority of our
messenger. What is that authority?
His words in themselves are an evidence.
His words in themselves are binding.
That is an authority that belongs only
to Muhammad Sam. Wasallam. To the point
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
[Silence]
He said, "I swear by Allah that if MS
was alive today
that he would have no choice but to
follow me and pledge his allegiance to
me." And in another wording, he said, "I
swear by Allah that if MS was alive
today and you all obeyed him and left me
and my obedience, you would all go
astray." If we followed MS, the one who
speaks to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Why? Because MS is not our messenger.
Our messenger is Muhammad sallall.aii,
the im and foremost of the messengers of
Allah.
He says
after that our allegiance belongs to the
leaders of the Muslim whatever those
leadership positions are. Notice how the
leadership and the allegiances to the
position
even if we happen to disagree or even
disrespect the person who holds that
position.
For instance, a person obeys his parent,
which is a type of leadership position,
not because his parent earned his
obedience, not because his parent is
worthy of his respect, it's because he
has that position of parenthood. And so
even if we are faced with a person who
does not deserve that position, someone
who is
unqualified or someone who does not
belong in that position, it does not
mean that we are necessarily respecting
him. But we respect the position,
the position of the scholars. That is a
type of leadership. the position of the
general rulers, the Khalifa, the
governors,
the area mayors, the clerks, all of
these people as you go down in rank,
these are all considered to be
leadership positions of the Muslims, not
of the non-Muslims.
He says
and our allegiance is to every Muslim,
every Muslim. And part of that is
advising our Muslim brothers. We advise
them. Why? Because I owe them loyalty.
And I have to tell them what they need,
not what they want. This is part of
their allegiance to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Therefore,
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam made this statement very short.
Why? So that you and I and everyone else
could easily memorize it. There's just
one sentence.
Memorize it. Make it your mantra.
repeated in your head over and over and
over that this is to whom my allegiance
belongs. And anyone else who threatens
that allegiance by by near or far than
this person does not receive my loyalty
or my allegiance. My loyalties lie with
Allah and his book and his messenger and
the leaders of the Muslim and every
subsequent Muslim.
Subhanahu waala.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.